This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I have a couple announcements before we get started. We're currently reconfiguring all the different moving parts of the show so that we can start producing weekly episodes starting on February 4th, 2014. That involves moving the office to downtown Oakland, getting our new producer, Katie Mingle, out here to the West Coast, and attending all the various Kickstarter fulfillment details of which there are many. Thanks again for that Kickstarter. That was
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在节目开始前，我有几个通知要宣布。我们目前正在重新配置节目的各个环节，以便从2014年2月4日开始制作周播节目。这包括将办公室搬到奥克兰市中心，让我们的新制作人凯蒂·明格尔来到西海岸，并处理各种Kickstarter众筹回报的事宜，其中有许多细节。再次感谢大家对Kickstarter的支持。那真是
pretty awesome. But even though we're up to our eyeballs and back office stuff, I still want to play some great radio for you. And this week, we have a story from our friend Nate Dimeo of the palace. The subject is right in our wheelhouse, so I thought you'd like it. Enjoy. Elevators are old. They would have to be because it is in our nature, right? To rise. So history, even ancient history, is thick with things that lift other things, ropes and platforms and weights and pulleys, with people to pull them. When the slaves of Rome were served up to the wild beasts at the Colosseum, other slaves pushed the wheels that pulled the ropes that lifted the platforms, that sent them up from the darkness below ground, up into the sun and the roar of the crowd, and of the lions.
太棒了。但尽管我们忙得焦头烂额，我还是想为你播放一些精彩的广播。本周，我们带来了来自“记忆宫殿”（Memory Palace）的朋友内特·迪梅奥的一个故事。这个主题非常契合我们的风格，我想你会喜欢的。尽情享受吧。电梯是很古老的东西。它们本该如此，因为向上升起是我们的本能，对吧？所以历史，甚至是古代历史，都充满了各种用来提升重物的装置：绳索、平台、重物和滑轮，还有负责拉动它们的人。当罗马的奴隶在斗兽场被当作野兽的盘中餐时，另一些奴隶则推动着转轮，拉动绳索，升起平台，将他们从地下的黑暗中送往地面，迎着阳光、人群的呐喊声，以及狮子的咆哮。
and the roar of the crowd and of the lions. In China and Hungary and Mollse Michel, one can find monks in kings and courtesans and construction materials and meals fit for queens and sorted consorts, rising up, while some slave or servant or caged animal somewhere pulled on some rope or pushed some piece of wood around and around and around. One man in France spent the year 1743 inside a chimney, waiting for a belt ring, so he could pull a rope through a pulley, and hoist King Louis XV up in a flying chair from the ground to his bedroom balcony, rather than have him walk up a single flight of stairs. Elijah Otis was too sick for the family business. He was a good looking kid and smart as a whip, but he was kind of weakling. And when he was 19, he moved away from the family farm in Vermont to figure out something to do for a living.
以及人群和狮子的咆哮。在中国、匈牙利和圣米歇尔山，人们可以发现僧侣、国王、名妓、建筑材料，以及供女王和各路伴侣享用的美餐，都在不断上升，而某个地方的奴隶、仆人或笼中动物则在不停地拉着绳子，或者一圈又一圈、一圈又一圈地推动着某种木头。法国曾有一个男子在1743年整整一年都待在烟囱里，等待着铃声响起，好让他通过滑轮拉动绳子，用一把飞椅将路易十五国王从地面吊到他的卧室阳台，而不是让他自己走上一层楼梯。伊利亚·奥蒂斯因为身体太弱，无法从事家族生意。他长得很清秀，聪明绝顶，但有点弱不禁风。19岁时，他离开家乡佛蒙特州的农场，去寻找生计。
Something where he wouldn't have to exert himself. Sell anything bought or processed. Process anything sold, bought or processed. Or lift heavy things. He wound up in a furniture factory where he and his co-workers spent their days sanding curves and decorative knobs into bedposts. And Otis spent his nights designing a better way to do it.
找一份不需要出力的工作。买卖或加工任何东西。加工任何买卖或加工的东西。或者搬运重物。他最终在一家家具厂找到了一份工作，他和同事们整天都在床柱上打磨出优美的曲线和装饰性的圆钮。奥蒂斯则利用晚上的时间设计更好的制作方法。
He invented a machine, a kind of lathe that sped up the process. It increased output, it made the men's jobs a little easier, and it opened up the aesthetic possibilities of the bedpost in new thrilling ways. Nobs upon nobs upon nobs upon nobs. In his boss was so impressed that he took him off the floor and made him head engineer of the Mays and Burns Bed Factory of Yonkers, New York. So Otis got to work trying to solve one of the biggest problems in the place. The factory had a lift, it had an elevator. A lot of factories were starting to have them then. These were simple machines.
他发明了一台机器，一种能加快加工过程的车床。它提高了产量，让工人们的工作变得轻松了一些，并以令人兴奋的新方式开拓了床柱的美学可能性。圆钮上套圆钮，圆钮叠圆钮。他的老板印象深刻，于是将他调离车间，任命他为纽约州扬克斯梅斯与伯恩斯床厂的总工程师。于是奥蒂斯开始着手解决厂里的一个最大问题。这家工厂有一个升降机，也就是电梯。当时很多工厂都开始配备这种设备。这些都是简单的机器。
Just picture a platform that could be pulled off the ground up to a second story on a chain or set of cables or ropes. Sometimes the ropes would be pulled by a steam power winch, but the one in the maze and burns bedfactory of Yonkers, New York was pulled by a draft horse. In one day, the horse is pulling on the rope, which is pulling the wooden platform loaded with lumber and tools up to the second floor. In the rope snapped. The platform plummeted, dropping 15 feet, slamming down onto the floor and onto one of the men below, sending its cargo careening, smashing into the scattering workers.
想象一下这样一个平台：它可以通过链条、一组缆绳或绳索，从地面拉升到二楼。有时绳索由蒸汽动力绞盘拉动，但纽约扬克斯梅斯与伯恩斯床厂的那个是由一匹役马拉动的。有一天，马拉着绳索，绳索拉着装满木材和工具的木质平台向上升往二楼。突然绳索断了。平台急坠而下，下落了15英尺，重重地砸在地板上，砸中了一名工人，其搭载的货物也失控倾覆，砸向四处逃散的工人们。
Just a few years later, in 1843, Elijah Otis stood on a wooden platform, 30 feet off the ground. The elevator was loaded with lumber and tools and barrels, just like the one had been that day in Yonkers. And down below, on the floor, stood hundreds of gentlemen and ladies, who didn't want to spend their night out in the town being crushed by construction equipment. They had come to the Crystal Palace exhibition to see the gathered wonders of the world. A massive structure of steel and glass had risen in Manhattan, where Bryant Park is today. It was America's first world's fair, and New York was psyched. In the gentleman and, after walking through these sculpture gardens in the art galleries, found themselves in a great hall filled with industrial equipment. And while they stood on the floor of the main hall, moonlight streaming through the
短短几年后的1843年，伊利亚·奥蒂斯站在一个离地30英尺的木制平台上。电梯里装满了木材、工具和木桶，就像当年扬克斯的那台电梯一样。而在下方的地板上，站着数百名绅士和淑女，他们可不想在城里过夜时被建筑设备压成肉饼。他们来到水晶宫展览会，是为了见证世界各地的奇观。一座由钢铁和玻璃构成的宏伟建筑在曼哈顿拔地而起，就在今天的布莱恩特公园所在地。这是美国的第一次世博会，纽约为此兴奋不已。绅士和淑女们穿过雕塑花园和艺术画廊后，来到一个摆满工业设备的大大展厅。当他们站在主大厅的地板上，月光透过
glass roof, craning their necks to see Otis and his elevator floating in air, they may not have known that they were looking at the future. Because they had seen elevators before, and seen one adventure after another come up with some new way to get from one floor to another. So here was one more. Admittedly he was higher than they'd seen before, up three stories instead of two. But there was no way this thing was going to catch on. Because who in their right mind was going to ride a three-story
玻璃屋顶倾泻而下，伸长脖子看着奥蒂斯和他的电梯悬浮在空中时，他们可能并不知道自己正在见证未来。因为他们以前见过电梯，也见过一个又一个冒险者想出各种新方法在楼层之间移动。所以这只是又一个新玩意儿。诚然，它比他们见过的都要高，上升了三层而不是两层。但这东西绝对不可能流行起来。因为谁会脑子正常到去坐一部
elevator? Fall from the second floor, break your leg, fall from the third, you break your neck. So they watched Otis, and watched his son nearby, raise a sword, and then bring it down like an executioner, slicing the rope that held up the platform. And not in-screened. And then it cheered. Elijah Otis didn't invent the elevator. He invented the brake. The little metal piece that catches the car and stops it from plummeting if the cable that holds it up stops holding it up. Elijah Otis didn't invent the elevator, but his sons kind of invented the modern world. The Otis brothers convinced the world to aim higher. The tallest buildings back in the
三层楼高的电梯？从二楼摔下来会断腿，从三楼摔下来就会断脖子。于是他们看着奥蒂斯，看着他身边的儿子举起一把剑，然后像刽子手一样挥下，砍断了悬挂平台的绳索。结果却没有尖叫声。人群随后欢呼起来。伊利亚·奥蒂斯并没有发明电梯。他发明的是刹车。那个小金属部件可以在固定电梯轿厢的缆绳失效时，将其卡住并阻止其坠落。伊利亚·奥蒂斯没有发明电梯，但他的儿子们却某种程度上发明了现代世界。奥蒂斯兄弟说服全世界把目标定得更高。19世纪的最高建筑，
19th century, the tallest buildings that weren't churches or lighthouses, which were all show off the spires anyway. We're just a few stories tall. In part, these buildings were held down by the lack of engineering know-how. But just as much, they were held down by stairs. People could only climb so many. So the brothers Otis came up with a killer sales pitch. Higher was better. They targeted Hotels first, and convinced them to turn the idea of luxury, quite literally, upside down.
那些不是教堂或灯塔的最高建筑——它们无论如何都只是为了炫耀尖顶——其实只有短短几层高。在某种程度上，这些建筑受限于缺乏工程技术。但同样地，它们也受限于楼梯。人们只能爬那么高。于是奥蒂斯兄弟想出一个杀手级的销售说辞：更高才是更好。他们首先将目标锁定在酒店，并字面意义上彻底颠覆了豪华的概念。
Before the elevator, the best rooms were on the bottom floor. You didn't have to walk. Stairs were for suckers. But the Otis brothers convinced Hotels it should be the other way around. The first floors were the one on the street, with the Hoi Palloy and their noise and their sweat and their fruit cart sticking in the sun, in worse the horses and the things horses do. Wasn't a king's throne supposed to be higher than his servants? Wasn't a lord supposed to lord over?
在电梯出现之前，最好的房间在底层。你不用走路。爬楼梯的都是笨蛋。但奥蒂斯兄弟说服酒店，情况应该反过来。一楼是临街的，有平民百姓及其制造的噪音、汗水和在阳光下散发恶臭的水果车，还有马匹以及马匹会做出的那些事。国王的宝座不应该比他的仆人更高吗？领主难道不应该高高在上吗？
Why shouldn't the wealthy traveler be above it all? In the hotel's bit, when they built high, in the wealthy travelers like the view. And when it came time for them to build their next office building, they built higher still, and they bought from the Otis Elevator Company. Building's grew, three stories to four to six. In the Elevators group better and faster. To the delight of passengers who loved the thrill ride of hurtling 70 feet at speeds of
为什么富有的旅客不能凌驾于这一切之上呢？酒店动心了，他们建得很高，而富有的旅客也喜欢这种视野。当他们需要建造下一座办公楼时，他们建得更高了，并且向奥蒂斯电梯公司采购了设备。建筑越来越高，从三层到四层再到六层。电梯也变得更好、更快。乘客们对此欣喜若狂，他们热爱以每分钟
600 feet per minute, up to the penthouse on the seventh floor. But though the Otis safety elevator relieved them of the fear of falling to their dooms, it created a new concern. One ginned up in the papers and in the esteemed pages of the Scientific American, which warned of the horrors of something called elevator sickness. Acute dizziness and nausea, owed to the spacious fact that when an elevator comes to a stop, not all of your organs stop at the same time. The best way to combat this, it seems, was to brace your head up against the ceiling
600英尺的速度将自己抛向70英尺高空的惊险刺激，直奔七楼的顶层公寓。然而，尽管奥蒂斯安全电梯解除了他们对坠落深渊的恐惧，却引发了另一种担忧。这种担忧在报纸和《科学美国人》备受尊崇的版面上被炒作起来，警告人们注意一种被称为“电梯病”的恐怖现象。由于电梯停下时，你的内脏并不会同时停下来，从而导致急性的头晕和恶心。对抗这种情况的最佳方法，似乎是在电梯停下时
of the elevator as it came to a stop. So all of you stopped at the same time. The regional headquarters of the Otis elevator companyator Company in my hometown is a one-story building. I just always thought that was kind of funny. At another world's fair, in Chicago in 1870, the crowd gathered to watch a dramatic demonstration of the latest in Elevator safety technology. Earlier that year, a seven-story building in New York became the tallest in the world. And it had every architect, and every illustrator in the Sunday Circulars drawing up visions of the cities of the future,
将头部紧紧抵住电梯天花板。这样你的全身就能同时停下来了。奥蒂斯电梯公司在我家乡的地区总部居然是一栋单层建筑。我一直觉得这挺搞笑的。在另一场世博会上，即1870年的芝加哥世博会上，人群聚集在一起观看最新电梯安全技术的戏剧性演示。那年早些时候，纽约一栋七层建筑成为世界最高建筑。这让所有建筑师和周日增刊的插画师们都在构想未来的城市愿景，
with gleaming towers climbing, soaring, 11, and even 14 stories. And though people had grown to trust the Otis break at four and five stories, what would happen if something happened? And you were up there scraping the sky. So the fairgoers went out to a field where another inventor had constructed a temporary elevator shaft. This one a hundred and nine feet tall, and they watched as passengers climbed to the top and stepped inside. And they watched as someone cut the rope to the elevator and it dropped, plummeting for
闪闪发光的塔楼不断攀升、翱翔，达到11层甚至14层。虽然人们已经开始对四五层楼高的奥蒂斯刹车产生信任，但如果出事了会怎么样？当你身处高空直插云霄时。于是，世博会的参观者们来到一块场地，另一位发明家在那里搭建了一个临时的电梯井。这个井高达109英尺，他们看着乘客爬到顶部并走进去。接着他们看着有人割断了电梯的绳索，电梯随之坠落，
a few exhilarating seconds before it came to a slow stop, cushioned by a pocket of compressed air. And then the crowd politely applauded. The outcome never having really been in doubt what with the wonders American inventors were coming up with all the time. And really, they had seen this trick into World's Fair before. and doubt what with the wonders American inventors were coming up with all the time. And really, they had seen this trick at a world fair before. They may have been more excited, however.
在经历了几秒钟令人肾上腺素飙升的下落后，被一个压缩空气囊缓冲并缓缓停下。随后，人群礼貌地鼓掌。由于美国发明家们层出不穷的各种奇思妙想，结局其实从未真正悬念。说实话，他们以前在世博会上也见过这种把戏。然而，他们可能会更加兴奋，
Had they known that the same technique had been tested in secret in Boston not long before. And when the elevator car holding eight volunteers dropped on command, the air pressure in the shaft that was supposed to cushion its descent blew out the walls of the elevator shaft, leaving nothing to stop the free-fallen car but Massachusetts soil. Many bones were broken. Lives passed before eyes. All eight of them nearly died. Something the eight volunteers who climbed into the elevator in Chicago hadn't been told. The Burj Khalifa Tower rises 2,722 feet above the desert in Dubai. It has history's tallest and fastest elevator, and notice.
如果他们知道不久前波士顿曾秘密测试过同样的技术。当载有八名志愿者的电梯轿厢听令下落时，本应用来缓冲下落的井内气压直接炸毁了电梯井的壁，导致这个自由下落的轿厢除了撞上马萨诸塞州的泥土外，没有任何东西能将其拦下。许多骨头断了。人生往事浮现眼前。这八个人差点全都丧命。这是那些在芝加哥爬进电梯的八名志愿者所不知道的事。迪拜的哈利法塔高耸于沙漠之上，高达2722英尺。它拥有历史上最高、最快的电梯，值得注意的是。
It travels 30 feet a second, taking you 124 floors in about a minute. Reviewers have called the experience mildly exhilarating. Six stories first appeared on the Memory Palace podcast by Nate Dimaio. A couple years ago we commissioned another piece from the Memory Palace. I called it a bridge to the sky, Nate called it a stretch. So while we're here talking about how great the Memory Palace is, I thought I'd play that one for you too. Bradford Gilbert had spent his career close to the ground.
它以每秒30英尺的速度运行，大约一分钟就能带你到达124层。评论者称这种体验为“温和的惊险刺激”。这六个故事最初出现在内特·迪梅奥的“记忆宫殿”播客中。几年前，我们向“记忆宫殿”约了另一篇作品。我称之为“通往天空的桥梁”，内特称之为“延伸”。所以既然我们在这里谈论“记忆宫殿”有多棒，我想我也把那篇放给你们听听。布拉德福德·吉尔伯特（Bradford Gilbert）的职业生涯一直与地面密不可分。
At 23 he took a job as the architect for the New York Lake Erie in Western Railroad. It was 1878. The Western was basically just Western New York and just left of Lake Erie. Were Gilbert walked ridges and delts, mapped its contours and calculated its slopes and rises, built bridges and trussles, and new ways to go over the river and through the woods, It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed.
23岁时，他接受了一份工作，担任纽约伊利湖和西部铁路公司的建筑师。那是1878年。西部铁路基本上就是指纽约州西部以及伊利湖左侧的地区。吉尔伯特在那里跋涉于山脊和三角洲，绘制其轮廓，计算其坡度和起伏，建造桥梁和高架桥，寻找跨越河流穿过森林的新途径。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。
It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed.
那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。
It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed. It was a place where the building was constructed. in Oyster Bay and Tom's River in Essex Falls. The places you waited to get places where things actually happened. But buy a ticket there for Manhattan or St. Louis and you can see other architects building more impressive things.
那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。那是建筑正在被建造的地方。牡蛎湾、汤姆河畔和埃塞克斯福尔斯。那些你等待着去往真正发生事情的地方的地方。但在那里买一张去曼哈顿或圣路易斯的车票，你就能看到其他建筑师建造的更加宏伟的建筑。
You could disembark and marvel at six and eight and ten story structures. Mammoth buildings of stone and brick in rod iron holding court on whole city blocks like medieval fortresses made for the kings of the modern American insurance industry. The emperors of imports and exports. One of these was looking to expand his empire. John Noble Sterns had made a lot of money importing silk and he was looking to make a lot more in real estate. He bought some land in a prime location at 50 Broadway.
你可以下车，惊叹于六层、八层和十层的建筑。那些用石头和砖块建造的庞然大物，以及支撑着整个街区的熟铁建筑，就像是为现代美国保险业巨头建造的中世纪城堡。进口和出口帝国的君主们。其中一位正打算扩张他的帝国。约翰·诺布尔·斯特恩斯（John Noble Sterns）通过进口丝绸赚了大钱，他正指望在房地产领域赚取更多。他在百老汇50号黄金地段买下了一些土地。
It was the perfect place for a new office building, right downtown near the ports, in the heart of the growing financial industry. But there was a problem. The lot was less than 22 feet wide. There are rules that dictate what you can build in how. Rules of physics and rules of men who sit on various bureaucratic boards and bodies. And those rules dictated that if Sterns wanted to build one of those ten story office towers that were all the rage in 1888, he would need to build walls of stone and brick that were 5 feet thick, with itty bitty
这是建造新办公楼的绝佳地点，就在市中心港口附近，处于不断发展的金融业核心地带。但有个问题。这块地皮宽度不到22英尺。有些规则规定了你能建什么以及怎么建。物理学的规则，以及坐在各种官僚委员会和机构中的人们制定的规则。这些规则规定，如果斯特恩斯想建造那种在1888年风靡一时的十层办公大楼，他就必须建造5英尺厚的石墙和砖墙，并配上小小的
windows. And that left room for an interior that was only 11 feet wide. Slice off a few feet for a hallway, a few for a bathroom, a couple for a coat closet, another for some filing cabinets in an umbrella stand. And he would be asking the quintessential modern titan of American industry to work in a dark cell, better suited for a monk, illuminating a manuscript. Sterns asked all the best architects for a solution. They had built medieval bell towers, come man-hatten bank headquarters. They had made midtown hotels that looked like mountain fortresses. But what Sterns wanted was a flagstaff.
窗户。这样留给内部的空间就只有11英尺宽。再扣除几英尺作走廊、几英尺作浴室、两英尺作衣帽间，还要留出空间放文件柜和雨伞架。而他却在要求现代美国工业的典型巨头们在一个更适合僧侣手抄经文的黑暗牢房里工作。斯特恩斯向所有最优秀的建筑师寻求解决方案。他们建造过中世纪的钟楼，设计过曼哈顿的银行总部。他们建造过看起来像山地城堡的中城区酒店。但斯特恩斯想要的却是一根旗杆。
What Sterns wanted was a blade of grass. And they weren't in the blade of grass building business. They told them it couldn't be done. Everyone except Bradford Gilbert. The in-house architect for the New York, Lake Erie, and Western Railroad had an idea. Even the simplest train trip between two of his backwater stations often required stunning feats of engineering. Hundreds of tons of cars and cargo hurtle over thin tressels and bridges every day. What if he turned one of those bridges on its head? What if he was one of the steel frames that so capably carried trains and built it up instead
斯特恩斯想要的是一叶小草。而他们可不是做“小草建筑”生意的。他们告诉他这根本不可能做到。除了布拉德福德·吉尔伯特外，所有人都是如此。这位纽约、伊利湖和西部铁路公司的内部建筑师却有一个想法。即使是他那些落后车站之间最简单的火车旅行，也常常需要惊人的工程壮举。数百吨的列车和货物每天都在细细的高架桥和桥梁上飞驰而过。如果他把其中一座桥梁颠倒过来会怎样？如果他采用那种能够出色承载火车的钢框架，将其向上建造而不是向
of out? He told Sterns that if he did this, the walls wouldn't have to be 5 feet thick. They could be 9 inches. And in the 20-foot wide office spaces that that would create, the quintessential modern Titan of American industry would have room to stretch out his legs, while he made out his rent-check to John Noble Sterns. They would call it the tower building. Sterns loved the idea.
外扩展呢？他告诉斯特恩斯，如果这样做，墙壁就不必有5英尺厚。它们可以只有9英寸厚。在由此创造出的20英尺宽的办公空间里，现代美国工业的典型巨头将有足够的空间伸展双腿，同时把租金支票开给约翰·诺布尔·斯特恩斯。他们决定将其命名为“大楼”（Tower Building）。斯特恩斯很喜欢这个想法。
For a while, until people started telling him it was completely bananas. First, he heard it from business associates, people looking out for his investment. Then it was the press, which called the project and the men behind it, idiotic. Architects came in from all over the country to watch the tower building rise, to pour over Gilbert's blueprints. And they all pretty much agreed. Gilbert and Stern's were idiots. The walls were just too thin.
有一段时间是这样的，直到人们开始告诉他这简直荒谬透顶。首先，他从商业伙伴、那些为他的投资操心的人那里听到了这种说法。接着是媒体，它们将这个项目及其背后的男人称为白痴。全国各地的建筑师纷纷赶来观看大楼的拔地而起，仔细研读吉尔伯特的蓝图。他们几乎得出了一致的结论。吉尔伯特和斯特恩斯都是白痴。墙壁实在太薄了。
The foundation was too narrow. Sure, those quintessentially modern men could stretch out their legs in sunny 20 foot wide offices stacked up like cardboard boxes. But they could also be crushed to death when the first stiff wind came and blew the building down. Stern's ask Gilbert to change the plans, and he refused. He said he was so confident in his design that he would move his offices to the top two floors of the building. If the building blew down, he would have the farthest of fall, in the longest time to consider his mistakes, before he slammed into the pavement. The first stiff winds of a hurricane blew into Manhattan on a Sunday morning in 1889.
地基太窄了。当然，那些现代典型男士可以在像鞋盒一样堆叠起来的、阳光充足的20英尺宽办公室里伸展双腿。但当第一阵强风吹来把大楼吹倒时，他们也会被压得粉身碎骨。斯特恩斯要求吉尔伯特修改计划，遭到拒绝。他说他对自己的设计信心十足，以至于他要将自己的办公室搬到大楼的最高两层。如果大楼被风吹倒了，他将体验到最远距离的坠落，并有最长的时间来反思自己的错误，然后重重地砸在人行道上。1889年星期天的早晨，飓风的第一阵强风吹入了曼哈顿。
The tower building stood nearly complete, and people lined the streets to watch it tumble. By late morning the crowd numbered in the hundreds, the curious, the morbid, the newspaper men who were professionally both, and as the wind roared, a man pushed through the crowd. He walked to the base of the tower, to a construction ladder, and began to climb. When Bradford Gilbert reached the top of his tower, the wind whipped through its skeleton frame in more than 80 miles an hour. It was too strong for him to stand in the girders that crossed in the center of what he hoped would
大楼即将完工，人们在街头排起长队等着看它坍塌。到了上午晚些时候，人群多达数百人，有好奇者、有猎奇者、有把这两者当作职业的报纸记者。随着狂风怒吼，一个男人挤过人群。他走到大楼底部，走向一座建筑梯，开始向上爬。当布拉德福德·吉尔伯特爬到他的大楼顶端时，狂风以超过每小时80英里的速度穿过其骨架结构。风实在太大了，以至于他无法在那些在他希望将来成为顶层公寓办公室的中央交叉的钢梁上站稳。
someday be his penthouse office. It was too strong to look down at the crowd who were probably placing bets on whether he would die by being blown off the building or simply in the crushing force of its collapse. But he crawled out to the center of the building and pulled from a bag rope with a lead way to touch to one end, who tied the other end to a girder and tossed the weight down through the empty floor's blow. When he got to the ground he looked up and saw the lead way hanging in mid-air, stock still, held up by a building that wasn't going anywhere. The next day, the papers called Gilbert immediate, and this time he probably deserved it.
风大得让他无法低头去看人群，那些人可能正在打赌他究竟会被风从楼上吹下去，还是会在大楼坍塌的毁灭性力量中丧生。但他还是爬到了大楼中央，从包里掏出一根一端系着铅锤的绳子，将另一端绑在钢梁上，然后把重物从空荡荡的楼层向下抛去。当他到达地面时，他抬头看到铅锤悬挂在半空中，纹丝不动，被一座哪儿也没去的大楼稳稳托住。第二天，报纸称赞吉尔伯特是个天才，这一次他大概实至名归。
They admitted his idea was genius. In three years after, Gilbert could sit in his pan house office in the tower building and he could look out of his large window, stretch out his legs, and watch a whole city stretching ever higher as it took his idea and built on it. The Memory Palace by Nate Dimaio 99% Invisible is San Greenspan, Avery Truffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of cool stuff at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio.
他们承认他的想法简直是天才之举。三年后，吉尔伯特可以坐在大楼顶层公寓的办公室里，透过大窗户向外眺望，伸展双腿，看着整座城市吸收了他的想法并在此基础上不断向上延伸，变得越来越高。内特·迪梅奥制作的“记忆宫殿”。99% Invisible由桑·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特勒夫曼和我罗曼·马斯制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 地方公共广播电台 KALW 以及 99pi.org 酷炫事物美国研究所的项目。广播塔皮奥。
From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。